bloomberg reports sales at Macy's and
Kohl's fell even faster than expected
their shares and their shares fell
stocks of other department store chains
also tumbled in a new earnings report
released yesterday net sales for Macy's
plunged seven and a half percent sales
at Kohl's declined 2.7 percent shares of
Macy's Kohl's JCPenney and Nordstrom
dropped between 7 and 17 percent the
brokerage firm Credit Suisse predicts
more than 8,600 brick-and-mortar stores
will close this year that would be a
record CBS News financial contributor
Mellody Hobson is here good morning I'm
so glad you're here I've been dying to
talk to you about this I mean not only
the sales dropping but Macy's saying
they're going to close a hundred stores
what is this trend signal secular trend
secular this is not cyclical this is a
bloodbath
it really is normally I use very
moderated words in describing math it's
not moderate so bad on a moderate and
when you think about the fact we've been
in an economic expansion wages are up
oil prices are low consumer confidence
is very very high this should be a
period of manna from heaven for retail
and it is not so what's happening what
and is it because of Amazon you know
what's wrong it's not just Amazon so
Amazon gets a lot of the conversation
when really when you think about it they
are representing about 45% of all online
sales so everything we buy nearly half
is being bought at Amazon online however
85% of retail sales are still occurring
in brick-and-mortar stores 85% so most
of us the vast majority of us are
walking into a store to buy things part
of this has been driven by the fact that
malls were over built from 1970 to 2015
malls were built at twice the rate of
the US population growth melody I still
like going to the mall but I guess we
need to all just let that go
but there are some retailers that are
doing ok all retailers are not created
equal
that's correct so some of them are doing
well those are ones where it's
experiential where they have a real
niche as well as the discounters are
still doing very well so I won that that
is experiential that is
doing very well is uLTA Beauty I mean
Beauty Sephora Ulta they are hitting a
cover off the ball Ulta stock is up 17%
this year largely driven by the fact
they have a huge rewards program 20
million people participate in their
loyalty program and a woman senior yeah
Mary Dylan yes she's fantastic so
interesting that you say that that
exponential experience you know I just
did an interview with Angela Erin's at
Apple magazine they're talking about
retail has to provide something other
than the product it has to be experience
you want to go to the store for a reason
that's right and one of the things
that's helping the beauty retailers is
YouTube there's a lot of these
demonstration videos around where you
have put them and then people are going
in and buying so what about Walmart
Walmart is actually doing better because
of their online has really picked up
they bought jet calm and that's actually
working so Walmart has been a story
there they're they're doing okay their
stock has done okay thank you very
interesting so charlie now you know when
you need to apply lipstick you can look
at it on youtube but first a Bolton buys
all right right org Illinois Gailen I
could give you a quick tutorial all
right you're welcome so you can do your
own video that too I would probably
actually break somebody help me